Tiger's not a smart you can work with a
tiger don't fall down in front of a
tiger don't fall down can't fall down
and tigers are all different some tigers
are easy to go with other Tigers no
[__] way can't turn your back either
right you don't do certain things I mean
lions are way better because Lions have
communication so when you go in there a
lion will tell you exactly how a lion's
feeling so they're way more predictable
and so when you're with a line you let
them they have to do their thing with
you they have to greet you just like a
pack animal
so when you understand their behavior
it's way more predictable Jaguar is the
reason you never see Jaguars in circuses
is because Jaguars can be cool that I
talked to the guy who he goes he showed
me all the scars he said a Jaguar you
can walk a jaguar or work with a Jaguar
for five years and then on a Tuesday
you've been doing the same thing in the
Jaguar Rose not today and just jumps and
just attempt